[Music]
foreign
welcome to Sky News breakfast now with
one day to go until Christmas rail
passengers have been advised to travel
only if necessary as a fresh rail strike
means that train services will finish by
around 3 P.M workers from the rmt union
are walking out again in a long-running
dispute over pay and conditions and
there are fears that the disruption
could have a knock-on effect on the
roads the AAA has issued an Amber
traffic warning with 17 million drivers
expected to join the annual Christmas
getaway
we did a survey and found that a third
of people who would normally take the
rail are now going to go by car and we
know the roads are busy already we've
seen car rental companies some of them
particularly in London the southeast
have got no cars left and there'll be a
combination of people getting away today
but also 20 still say they're going to
be doing shopping
well let's take a look at how things are
doing so far this morning Sky's Saba
choudary is at King's cross train
station while Aisha's ahead of surveying
the traffic from above the M25 so
morning to both of you saber to you
first of all how's it looking there at
the station
good morning well it's only just past
seven but we are only a few hours away
from some of the last trains going to
and from King's cross station with some
of the last trains uh departing from 3
00 p.m now the reason being is that the
ongoing Pages meet with the rmt union
and the government is ongoing union
members will be walking out from 6 p.m
today until 6 a.m on the 27th of
December and that's to disrupt uh
engineering works now just to give you a
flavor of some of the trains that are
going to be disrupted here at King's
cross today the last leads to London
train will be departing at quarter to 11
the last London to Houston 11 o'clock in
the last London to Manchester around 10
to 1 this afternoon now the rmt union
are saying that this dispute could have
been sold by Christmas but they are
blaming the government saying that they
are abdicating responsibility and have
gone missing they said yesterday they
could have come to the negotiating table
they could have set more dates to come
to the negotiating table but they have
failed to do so and they are not meeting
their requirements meanwhile the
government are saying that they have
acted fairly and responsibly Rishi sunak
saying that he has listened to the
payroll board recommendations that were
given to him and he is sad and
disappointed at the fact that there is
widespread industrial strike action
across the Christmas period and he's
saying that if I was to give in this
would in the long term impact things
like inflation so it's not in his
interest for the whole country to listen
and to come in and Cave into the demands
from his perspective now the impact that
this is going to have is going to be
it's going to manifest on the roads
later today now Journey times are
expected to be about 14 times longer
than they usually are and with sections
of the motorway affected as well
Saba thank you and those rail strikes
there are concerns that they could have
an impact on the roads as well Aisha
zaheed you're there looking out over the
the M25 how's it looking at the moment
at the moment but no doubt that will
change uh later on this morning it's
expected to be the second busiest day of
the Christmas period or the road today
around 16.6 million people expected to
make Journeys according to the AAA
that's slightly down from yesterday uh
when around 16.9 million Journeys were
made but as Zaba said it's going to be
impacted by the rail strikes the AAA say
about a third of people who would have
usually used the rails to get to their
destinations will now be taking to the
road and of course that's going to be
emphasized by the fact that Services
where they are running today are limited
lots of areas aren't covered at all and
services will be any much earlier around
3 P.M this afternoon now the worst
traffic on the roads is expected between
midday through to 1pm today and ready a
forewarning from the AAA they say that
the m6 southbound is likely to have
severe congestion but if anything yet is
go if anything we saw yesterday is to go
by then we should be seeing widespread
severe congestion so the advice to
motorists really is to make sure that
they're prepared for these long Journeys
today
okay Asha thanks very much indeed
well as you would have noticed it's been
a month dominated by strikes and there
are more set to come so let's take a
look at the calendar shall we and a
border four staff are set to continue
walkouts every day for the rest of the
year apart from next Tuesday Royal Mail
postal workers are also striking today
and as you've heard another four days of
rail strikes begins today with trains
set to finish running at around three
o'clock this afternoon
and on the roads there'll be strikes for
the rest of the year either by highway
traffic officers or driving examiners in
some parts of the country
and let's take a look at ambulance
workers while the GMB Union has now
canceled the plan strike next Wednesday
they have announced some fresh walkouts
on the 11th and the 23rd of January
and there's no respite from rail strikes
in the New Year rmt workers will again
walk out on the third fourth Sixth and
7th of January and separately as left
train drivers are also striking on the
fifth and nurses will strike again on
January the 18th and 19th and it's
understood they'll affect areas outside
this month's strike more areas
now at least 13 people have died as a
result of extreme weather gripping the
United States in the state of Montana
temperatures plunged below minus 45
degrees Celsius at least a million
households and businesses are without
power and thousands of flights have been
canceled it's been caused in part by a
weather phenomenon known as a bomb
cyclone
a bomb Cyclone is a storm that
intensifies very rapidly they form when
warm and cold air masses collide with
the warm air Rising fast through the
atmosphere and this triggers a sudden
drop in atmospheric pressure which draws
cooler air in to fill the Gap and as
long as the warm air continues to rise
pressure will continue to drop drawing
in more cold air underneath
in this case that cold air is being
drawn down from the Arctic and as you
can see here that's bringing freezing
conditions usually seen only in Northern
Canada down across much of the United
States
well millions of people are now facing
temperatures as low as minus 40 degrees
Celsius
with the freezing conditions stretching
as far south as Florida or the border
with Mexico our U.S correspondent James
Matthews reports
meteorologists are calling it a
one-center generation weather event it's
complicating the once in a Year
festivities to say the least
a pre-Christmas Mass mobilization has
been stalled by high winds heavy
snowfall and flooding in freezing
temperatures a number of cities have
declared states of emergency including
New York I called it a kitchen sink
storm because it is throwing everything
at us but the kitchen sink
we've had ice
flooding
snow freezing temperatures
and everything that mother nature could
wall up at us this weekend the Arctic
Blast has forced the cancellation of
several thousand flights and Counting
travel chaos is reflected on the roads
too in whiteout conditions
around 50 Vehicles were involved in a
number of crashes here on Interstate 80
the Ohio Turnpike
more than 200 million people are under
some form of weather advisory that's 60
percent of the U.S population
struck by the phenomenon dubbed a bomb
cycle
Mr worm intensifies really quickly you
can get uh very damaging winds and then
the winds over the water can create can
move water around so you get huge waves
uh storm surge uh coastal flooding can
be pretty terrible
the severe cold brings disruption but
also danger to life there have been
several deaths in Houston Texas a
homeless man in a wheelchair fell into a
fire pit he was found dead by
firefighters called to the scene
more than a million people have had
their power cut off as the storm battles
through North America before Christmas
it's seriously it's dangerously cold I
mean
I would advise anyone if you don't have
to be out don't go out and if you do go
out well you need to
bundle up there is no right time for
conditions like these it's certainly not
right now James Matthews Sky News in
Washington
the Sun newspaper has issued an apology
over Jeremy Clarkson's column about the
Duchess of Sussex the newspaper says it
regrets the publication and is sincerely
sorry for the column in which Mr
Clarkson described how much he hated
Meghan Markle
the piece became the most complained
about ever with the Press regulator ipso
receiving more than 20 800 complaints as
of 5 PM on Tuesday writing on Twitter Mr
Clarkson said he was horrified to have
caused so much hurt following the
backlash and that he would be more
careful in future
photograph has been released of King
Charles recording his first Christmas
message as Monarch the king is expected
to pay tribute to his mother the late
Queen Elizabeth during the address which
was recorded 10 days ago at St George's
Chapel in winter castle
now then let's get more on our top story
this morning and the latest wave of
strikes that are getting underway today
with rmt rail workers starting the first
of four days of industrial action well
let's get some reaction now I'm joined
by Norman Baker a former liberal
Democrat MP and now the director of
external Affairs at the campaign for
better transport at Norm Baker very good
morning to you so the rmt resuming their
strike later on today
do you back their decision to walk out
again
well I'm here for the campaign for a bit
of transport and we're not taking sides
in that sense
um for the government or for the unions
what I would say is that we're
determined to try to get people back on
trains as soon as possible and therefore
we urge both the government and the
unions to come to an agreement enables
Railway workers to get a decent pay uh
increase and to enable passenger to get
back on trains
well yes and I'll talk to you a little
bit more about what that could involve
but but first of all what you make at
the timing of this latest strike
um Christmas Eve of course I think the
walkout's from six o'clock tonight but
it's going to affect trains much earlier
in the day do you think that's
regrettable
well obviously anything was switching to
further people's movements is
regrettable and particularly at this
time of year when people are seeking to
join up with friends and family and
perhaps after a couple of years of covet
haven't had the normal Christmas
exchanges which we traditionally would
have taken place and of course uh let's
talk to the unions when they collect but
I would say that just objectively I
think it was a public relations mistake
for them to call Action on their
Christmas Eve when it just daily needs
to the public The public's been quite
supportive of the rail workers uh but
crawling calling a strike on Christmas
Eve is not actually a great move on my
view
do you think public opinion is shifting
well I think you're shifting for as far
as today's concerns
um but clearly the you know the public
probably think a play on both your
houses
um what they're seeing is some
intransigence on both sides I think and
the shape of any deal really is quite
clear it's been quite clear for day one
which is that you
reform some of the outdated terms
conditions under which real workers are
employed uh which I think even the
unions themselves were accepted to be
modernized and in return for that the
money released genuinely from efficiency
savings is you to give a decent pay
arise but you know it's not it's not
consensible of the government to try to
balance the unions into accepting for
example driver only operation at the
last minute negotiations which is what I
understood took place irrespective of
the values of that particular initiative
and you can't simply bounce that in at
the last minute it's almost as if they
didn't want an agreement
I mean while the rmt union is accusing
Ministers of going missing they say they
haven't had any meaningful talk since
last week what do you think the
government should do now
well I mean there's no substitute for
getting around the table and family has
a deal that's that's the reality of it I
was quite encouraged by the fact when
Mark Harper became transport secretary
he actually took the step to speak to
meet Lynch and to and to get rid of the
pretense that this was between the train
operators and and the and the unions
because we all know that the train
operators are working within a financial
envelope determined by the government by
the treasury in particular so it should
be in the recognition of that fact is a
it's a good thing to have happened
um so it's disappointing that if it's
true now that lots of you down and
talking because the public want this
resolved
uh and yes and yet the government would
argue there's not much money at the
moment times are tough and also they say
that any pay Rises that match inflation
or bust through inflation
um are going to themselves be
inflationary and their main task at the
moment is trying to keep inflation under
control because it makes everybody
poorer well I understand that argument
but I think it's difficult to argue that
um that workers across the the patch not
just rail workers but everybody
um should take a a pay increase way
below inflation which is what actually
has been offered
um that's a very difficult thing to
stomach and if you look at some of the
workers not the real workers necessarily
but the nurses uh they've actually had
effectively a real terms pay cut over
the last 10 12 years so it's a difficult
situation I understand the pressure from
the uh to avoid inflation but I think
there's got to be some halfway house and
the Improvement and productivity that
can come around from improving gender
conditions on the railways does release
genuine money so they're able to pay
increase to be to be afforded and that's
got to be the way forward you know we
can't go on indefinitely um with the
situation and
it's quite clear that if the
government's going to stick to this line
the the strike action and as far as
working so that the campaign for a bit
of Transport we don't think that's a
good outcome you know we promote public
transport that's what we do we think
public transport is good for the
environment good for the economy uh I I
go for social cohesion and you know
we're not having that now and uh your
report about the number of texture cars
on the road doesn't simply mean more
misery for drivers more congestion which
you will do it also means more carbon
emissions this is not a good outcome
a quick thought on on rail fares Before
I Let You Go um we got the announcement
that the fairs in England Will Rise by
up to 5.9 in March the government says
this is one of their biggest
interventions uh keeping the cost of
traveling uh the Rises below the rate of
inflation do you welcome that do you
feel that they've pitched it about right
well I wouldn't say pistol about right
because uh if you compare real first
with uh say a few duties for motorists
or indeed as a passengers Duty for air
Travelers what between them to
government uh freezing fuel Duty over 12
years and you're catching it last spring
uh cutting uh uh airport duty for uh
passengers
um on planes both of which are polluting
forms of Transport at the same time as
real Frozen bus first are increasing
that doesn't make any sense not least of
all the government's Net Zero strategy
having said that Mark Harper has broken
the link between the inflation rate at
last July which is what it's normally
determined and and the increasing
Affairs it could have been a lot worse
let's be frank about you could be 11 but
it's not that but it's still going to be
a huge increase for for real passengers
at the time when they're seeing putting
roping services
well Norman Baker from the campaign for
better transport really interesting to
get your take on things thanks very much
indeed for your time this morning and
happy Christmas thank you
this morning many homes across the south
of England are still without running
water with no guarantee of it returning
by Christmas Day residents in Hampshire
Sussex Hertfordshire Essex and Kent are
being told to pick up bottles from water
stations after the rapid change in
temperature caused many pipes to burst
Canadian rapper Tory Lanez has been
found guilty of shooting fellow Hip-Hop
star Megan V stallion in 2020 the
incident happened after an argument and
left her needing surgery to remove
bullet fragments from her feet Lane's
faces up to 22 years in prison when he's
sentenced next month
protesters have Clash with police on the
streets of Paris after three people were
shot dead at a Kurdish Cultural Center
unrest grew when it emerged the suspect
had previously been jailed for attacking
migrants officers say they're
investigating a possible racist motive
at least 20 people have died in a fire
at a home for the elderly in Siberia
Emergency Services said the entire
second floor of the building had been
gutted local officials have been quoted
in Russian media saying the home was
unregistered and couldn't be inspected
now tens of millions are hunkered down
as that icy blast strikes the U.S
luckily however it is much milder closer
to home
but what's the weather got in store for
us this Christmas Eve and is there any
chance of a white Christmas let's uh see
what our meteorologist at Kelsey McCabe
can tell us on that score not much sign
of snow here in London Kirsty is a white
Christmas still a possibility somewhere
it is actually Anna yes we are going to
see a white Christmas somewhere but as
you may expect it's not going to be the
same that is going to be further north
and to be honest to get a white
Christmas you don't need much all we
need to happen for a white Christmas in
the UK is for somewhere in the UK and
that could be there to Hebrides
somewhere in the UK to observe a single
flake of snow falling from the sky
during the 24 hours of Christmas day so
it's not perhaps the best definition
because I think many of us would love to
wake up to a blanket of snow on the
ground although hearing just how intense
the cold is across parts of North
America at the moment I'm kind of glad
it's not like that but anyhow we imagine
a white Christmas as a blanket of snow
on the ground the reality is we just
need a single flake of snow to fall from
the sky and that's probably going to
happen for parts of Scotland Northern
Ireland maybe even the Republic of
Ireland and also Northwest England as we
go through Christmas day but not till
later on
hello welcome back you're watching Sky
News breakfast now more than 6 000 UK
Armed Forces Personnel are celebrating
Christmas abroad this year after being
deployed on operations overseas and
let's talk to two of them now joining me
from Bahrain is Lieutenant Commander
Richard Burdette along with petty
officer Simon Davis and both are part of
the UK Maritime component command so a
very good morning to both of you and a
very happy Christmas to both of you
first of all um
is strange celebrating Christmas here
because it's quite warm at the moment
yes that must be a very strange feeling
not so much here so that's one advantage
of being there Simon Davis first of all
tell us why you're there what's the job
that you're doing at the moment and why
you're there over Christmas
um I'm here as part of the maritime
trade operations financial specialism
and we're here to support Merchant
shipping in the region and UK MCC is the
Strategic support to the Royal Navy's
effort
um uh to help coordinate a response to
make uh for Freedom navigation for
vessels
okay so really important work and
Richard I understand that if I'm right
correct me if I'm wrong this is the
first time that you've been away from
family
um this Christmas how are you feeling
about that how is that to to be working
away from home
and it's a really easy answer I mean to
us it's really simple I mean we've got
great accommodation here we've got great
food we've got great facilities we've
got two gyms on the British base and
some of the other facilities around us
um we're working in a headquarters of
highly motivated professional people but
it's harder for the families you know
it's to us it's a relatively simple role
it is a bit disorientating being in the
heat at Christmas and you've just missed
we had five seconds of rain just before
you got on some air but to us it's a
relatively um simple thing to be out
here we're well we're well supported but
um it's tougher for the families
would you get a chance Richard to
communicate with your families on
Christmas day tomorrow
oh yeah absolutely one of the the Modern
Age you know we've got great Wi-Fi in
our blog so we can talk to um we talk
about all the time friends on WhatsApp
and it sometimes it's very difficult
because it's so easy to be able to talk
to them but you're still separate so I
had to watch them putting up the
Christmas decorations while it was
sweltering out here but it was wonderful
that we can have that instant
communication here yeah it does make it
so much easier doesn't it and Simon
you've been away at Christmas before
haven't you have you found it in the
past
um I've I've always enjoyed it and and
just as we were just uh talking about uh
having the support of family and friends
back home um is crucial uh and and I I
think my family and friends is just as
proud of me for doing this as I am proud
of being at home serving with the Royal
Navy so
um that makes life so much easier and
with Communications and with uh the way
the ethos and the team work here
everyone supports each other
um so those people who uh have you know
family and children at home especially
uh we will get around and support each
other through through this time and
we'll have a great time and we're able
to still interact with our family and
friends which is so important well yeah
and we're looking at some pictures now
of some servicemen looking very festive
indeed uh tell us a little bit about how
you get to celebrate while you're there
how will you mark Christmas
oh did you do you know what tomorrow
um there'll be we've got a chaplain on
base and he'll do he'll do a church
service I think at 1100 Here Local
um and then we all all of us sit down
together there's a very old Naval
tradition that officers serve
um at Christmas meals so we'll be
serving and then if and this is a big if
they've been very good I think Santa
Claus and his elf will be visiting
during the meal possibly possibly how
amazing that's what I've heard that's
amazing you've got that inside
information but how might you have heard
that
well because I had to pick up the
costume yesterday
um but we're going to do it so we get
them we're really well supported by um
we're welfare packages from back home
from from members of the public so we've
had any number of them from all the
ships here all the staff on the naval
Support Facility or in the headquarters
we've all got packages from people back
home um and I can so the smile Club in
the Isle of Wight um in Glenn did know
um it's 15th chingford Scouts they've
all been sending packages out to us with
things like chocolates and crisps and
sweets and and nice letters then that
really helps it is it's very impressive
a couple years ago when I was first out
with the Royal Navy I've never been
full-time so always been regular uh
always been reserved sorry and uh to see
your package um sent by members of the
UK public
um what's actually quite special that
someone took their time and effort to
send it out to us and it's such a nice
reminder that people at home are
thinking of us and and I believe they're
thinking what we're doing a good job so
uh that's uh so thank you to everyone
who's done that oh that's that's really
lovely well we all send our Christmas
wishes to you all there from here at Sky
News very happy Christmas to both of you
uh Simon and Richard a real pleasure to
chat to you today and I hope you have a
good fun tomorrow and a good chance to
chat with your families as well thanks
very much indeed Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
that's really got me in the Christmasy
mood now
an Irish cellist whose online recitals
unexpectedly went viral during lockdown
says he's worried about the future of
social media Patrick Dexter says that
people should think about how much it
could be lost if negativity mean what
negativity means for platforms like
Twitter Sky's David Blevins traveled to
the West Coast of Ireland for his very
own recital
thank you
when Ireland had locked down Patrick
Dexter tuned up and ventured onto social
media I was a school teacher so I played
to my classroom of primary school
children and now playing to millions of
people online
his recitals from the West Coast turned
him into a global sensation what was it
they connected with the music the
landscape you're a beautiful dog or just
the freedom of this place during
lockdown as well yeah there's a certain
um like visceral impact that the west of
Ireland hasn't even you can feel it now
and this wild weather we're having it
and I think that mixed with the sound of
the cello and instrumental music in
general just the way that it touches
your soul and reaches into you and asks
for you to add something to it it
doesn't tell you what to think with
words it sort of suggests a Feeling
[Music]
foreign
Ed in County Mayo the ancestral homeland
of Joe Biden he has performed for the
U.S president and been viewed by
millions worldwide
you say that you underestimated the
extent to which social media could be a
force for good so you must have some
concerns about its direction of travel
now there is such negativity there but
let's just be aware that if this if we
lose this on Twitter in particular
because I think it has a special role to
play in that space
there's something really tragic being
lost and to see it go down the tubes as
things might be going is is I think a
great loss um but no matter what happens
if the ship of Twitter sinks at the
bottom of the Atlantic there I'll still
be playing my channel
most of Patrick's fans from around the
world engage with him on social media
but the postman did deliver one letter
here from Canada simply addressed to the
cellist who plays outside his Cottage in
mayo
his debut album entitled solos was the
best selling of its genre
music in this magical location having
introduced a whole new audience to the
cello David Blevins Sky News at Newport
and County Mayo
now time now to take you through the
morning papers with the UK editor of the
big issue Paul McNamee and the former
editor of the Daily Star Dawn Nissan
welcome back to both of you hope you got
a few Pleasant presents wrapped between
now and when I last spoke to you last
hour good work
um so let's kick off we've looked at
some of the front pages in the last hour
this hour we're delving inside aren't we
Dawn and you've picked out a story
inside of today's Daily Mail which is
reflecting on how the Border Force
strike went yesterday at those airports
where workers walked out
absolutely you've been covering it this
morning and uh that you know it's it's a
strike Advent calendar isn't it every
day there's several strikes going on
this is the Border Force One where a
thousand passport style of water a
Gatwick Heathrow Vermin Cardiff Glasgow
and Manchester
um and as is always these days our
wonderful armed forces were brought in
to help out
um and Incredibly the airports are
working more efficiently than they
normally do
um and lots of people have been putting
on social media about what they were
expecting hell getting through the
airports um but it was much more
efficient and quicker than usual and
then 250 000 Travelers are estimated at
the affected airports um today I think
Alone
um and every day there's going to be
disruption there by border Force until
the end of the year with the exception
of the 27th of December I'm not quite
sure what's happening there
um but you know you had a brilliant
interview just now Anna with those two
monthly officers out in Bahrain
um and I just want to wish all everyone
serving in our Armed Forces Personnel a
very Merry Christmas because they work
incredibly hard they've been roped into
cover motion strikes many of them are
very poorly paid themselves they work
selflessly they're not allowed to strike
by law obviously
um and they do so much for us and you
know they're covering jobs where people
are better paid than they are so fair
play to everyone who is working this
Christmas fill in the gaps at the
strikes of course but it's obviously not
just the airport center it's it's like
it's Planes Trains automobiles the only
thing I think might be making it through
Anna are the ranger I think they're
quite safe yeah I'm not worried about
them I feel very confident very often by
many Christmases so far so good on that
score let's keep with the with the
subject of strikes shall we Paul because
you wanted to talk about the Guardians
article
um inside its paper really reflecting on
this kind of stalemate between the
unions and ministers neither side
appeared to be budging
um how's the guardian covering this
well when you say neither side appear to
be budging I mean Mick Lynch is clearly
the most prominent of the union leaders
of the men and women representing their
members he has repeatedly said he's
ready to talk to government to try and
bring an end to the
um the real strikes but he has said here
that the government ministers have gone
missing
um which is making the situation worse
and he's not alone man and I think what
this story gets to because there's so
many unions involved as dawn has
mentioned well it's a GMB the RCN PCS
you're looking after the Border Force
there's there appears to be an
ideological battle going on now between
government who whether it's because they
don't want to or they can't negotiate
they don't have the wherewithal or the
people in government because of all the
chaos that there's been around
government
and they don't want to engage and uh
unions who want to represent so many
thousands of people this isn't just one
or two this isn't just a couple of
people asking for a pay raise it's about
the future of service across Britain for
all of us for a number of years and when
we have this these two forces bottling
together it leaves the rest of it's
stuck you know the trains are going to
stop at three today there's problems at
the airport and while Don says that the
Army have stepped in and helped that's
fine but that's hardly a long-term
solution so we we have this position and
I I think it is incumbent the government
and at present they are simply not
leading and they are allowing us to to
blame those who they claim are being
offered all sorts of of perks and and
extra money and there's no end in sight
everything suggests that it could get
worse in January I don't want to spoil
Christmas but that is very reality that
we're facing yeah and Paul very briefly
then what do you make of the government
saying we haven't got very much money
and we're worried that any pay Rises
that match inflation or go beyond
matching inflation or inflationary
themselves and that will affect
everybody what do you make of that then
well there are already some unions the
GMB have said well we'll come to us we
are if you make an offer that is not
quite at inflation we will talk about it
so there are unions here are saying if
that is the case come to us but also
it's wider than that it's terms and
conditions it's not just money in the
moment it's how people can live in the
future
okay well and well as you say we just
got to sit back and see what happens on
this haven't we with all those strikes
as you say across the calendar for the
time being let's move on to the front
page of the Daily Mail shall we Dawn you
wanted to talk about their headline
there NHS they say wasting Millions on
woke non-jobs
this is the perfect Daily Mail headline
isn't it Anna um
they have investigation in into how much
money is um wasted in inverter Commons
by the NHS on non-medical jobs um this
includes jobs like our diversity
officers a director of lived experience
I'm not entirely sure what that is but
they are being paid 115
000 pounds a year while nursing staff as
we know are taking industrial action and
I think the ones as Paul was discussing
as many of them but I think the one
strike that really does have public
support is that is the NHS and nursing
staff um being on strike um but you know
when you know nursing entry level can be
as low as 23 000 pounds
um and you've got a what's this a
director of lived experience again on
115 and the amount of investigated and
it's like 40 million pounds a year on
108 12
equality diversity and inclusion that's
enough 1 200 nurses or 1.3 million GP
appointments now 7.2 million people are
currently on the NHS waiting list that's
not a situation that's going to improved
and as Paul was saying earlier on you
know it's like what everyone now wants
to just talk to one another just get
around the negotiating table the
government is saying one thing the
unions are saying another meanwhile
everybody out here is going please just
come and sort the situation out it's not
going to get any better and as Paul
somewhat depressingly alluded to the New
Year doesn't look too much you know too
better either does it okay let's
um move on to the next one
um Paul you have picked out a story in
the express about
um Banks shutting down
I feel like I'm a merchant of Boom here
um with every story I'm looking at yeah
this is this is a story that the express
have picked up from which
um and and they've run some numbers over
the last eight years five thousand Bank
branches have closed across Britain and
there's another 200 Bank branches and
building societies that look like
they're going to shut next year and it's
a warning really because they're there
are still people who rely on cash that
there's an awful lot of Industry an
awful lot of work that that is Cash
business I work among big issue vendors
although half of them now except
cashless payments and we're trying to
help get more to do that an awful lot of
our vendors do rely on cash so I I know
right at the front line how cash is
important to people and as we move away
from it and there is the the Russian we
know so many Shops and and pubs and
other businesses that it only accept
cards the smart the marginalized people
are going to be shut out of society
further which is not a good and positive
thing so this really is just a warning
from which to say look hold on we need
to think and consider other people and
what we can do about it the other side
of it of course is the High Street as
these places are hollowed out and
there's less reason for people maybe to
go to the High Street it makes it more
difficult for high streets which are
suffering desperately to come back
and I'll stop now because everything I
say seems to be about a bleak future I'm
sure there are some positive things I'm
sure there are some positive things
there's just one word on my list here
Dawn for the next thing and it's
champagne that sounds pretty positive to
explain the story it's inside the
telegraph isn't it we've only got we
haven't got very long I have to do it
quite briefly
okay snobby about
some champagne
style these sang The Sword is now good
for producing champagne grapes so we can
start our own champagne industry but the
big boss of Moet above and Don Perignon
um I can pronounce these names
um has said no it's not happening your
soil isn't good enough and the only
place to produce decent champagne is
from us there you go so it wasn't that
positive really was it anyway it made us
all think a little bit about champagne
I'm trying yeah so you are I'll try
we've got another go to find a few
Christmasy stories as well but thanks
very much indeed for the moment I'll see
you in the next hour and we've got all
the top stories coming up next of course
sales guy needs breakfast today go away